[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem vorletzten Tag im Jahr Norbert
König ist auch dabei für den Sport guten
Abend schauen wir auf die Themen von
heute
Abschied von einer Legende die Welt
trauert um Pelé einen der besten
Fußballer aller Zeiten
Einblick in die Finanzen jahrelang hat
sich Donald Trump gewehrt jetzt hat der
US-Kongress seine Steuerunterlagen im
Internet veröffentlicht
und Erfolgsgeschichte bei der Darts WM
als erster Deutscher überhaupt erreicht
Gabriel Klemens das Viertelfinale
drei Tage Staatstrauer in Brasilien
Gedenkminuten in den Fußballstadien Fans
Sportler und Politiker die im huldigen
die Reaktionen auf den Tod Pelés zeigen
wie sehr dieser Mann weltweit bewundert
wird mit erst 17 Jahren war er schon
ganz oben schießt Brasilien 1958 zum
ersten Weltmeistertitel mit insgesamt
sechs Toren mehr als 1000 Folgen Pelé
zaubert mit dem Ball es heißt er mache
seinen Sport zur Kunst und dann 1970
sein dritter WM-Erfolg das schaffte bis
heute kein Spieler Oliver Flammen über
den Abschied von einem ausnahmekicker
König oh hey haben sie ihn genannt doch
behandelt haben ihn die Brasilianer fast
wie einen Gott die berühmte
Christusstatue in Rio ist in die
Nationalfarben Grün und Gelb getaucht
das Maracana Stadion strahlt golden
genhimmel das Land weint
fast jeder in Brasilien hat seine eigene
Geschichte zu Pelé Antonio ist mit
seinen Andenken vor das Albert
einstein-krankenhaus in Sao Paulo
gekommen wo Pele starb
belee ich habe ihn selbst spielen
gesehen ich habe sein tausendstes Tor im
Radio mitverfolgt Pelé wird von allen
hier geliebt er gehört zu unserem Erbe
dem Erbe Brasiliens sein Erbe das war
sein Aufstieg an dem alle teilnahmen von
dem Jungen aus armen Verhältnissen zum
jüngsten Weltmeister der Geschichte
edzone arandt und nassimento so sein
richtiger Name hob den Fußball auf ein
ganz neues Niveau frühere Weggefährten
sagten er überschreite dabei die Grenzen
der Logik
lange spielte er für den FC Santos den
Verein seiner Heimatstadt auch hier
versammeln sie sich jetzt vereint in
Trauer
ich kenne ihn seit ich ein kleiner Junge
war er kam oft hierher nach Santos um
sich unsere Spieler anzuschauen
abseits des Fußballs gab es auch Kritik
an Pelé als Sportminister umgab er sich
gerne mit den mächtigen machte
Privatgeschäfte mehrere seiner Ehen
scheiterten
und doch weltweit ist die Anteilnahme
riesig Neymar Ronaldo die größten dieser
Zeit verneigen sich vor ihm dem
vielleicht größten aller Zeiten Franz
Beckenbauer nennt Pelé einen
einzigartigen Freund der mit den Sternen
gespielt habe und doch auf dem Boden
geblieben sei Pelé selbst war seine
eigene Vergänglichkeit immer klar Pele
wird weiterleben sagte er einmal über
sich aber Edson ist ein normaler Mensch
der eines Tages sterben wird und das
vergessen die Leute manchmal
die Sterne mit denen Pelé jetzt spielt
hat die NASA grün-gelb für ihn
eingefärbt einen wie ihn da sind sich
Fußballfans auf der ganzen Welt wohl
einig wird es nie wieder geben
ja fragen wir Christoph röckerath in Rio
de Janeiro was bedeutet pellis Tod für
Brasilien
natürlich ist der Tod Pelés das
beherrschende Thema heute hier in
Brasilien aber weniger aus einer
emotionalen Schockstarre der Menschen
heraus dafür war eben doch sein Sterben
zu sehr zu verfolgen es gab in den
letzten Wochen immer wieder Meldungen
überall sein sich verschlechternen
Gesundheitszustand es geht viel mehr
darum dass die Brasilianer vielleicht
jetzt so ein bisschen Inhalten und
gemeinsam sich dessen bewusst werden und
würde irgendwas für eine großartige
Persönlichkeit für dieses Land hier
wirklich gegangen ist aber nicht nur
fußballerisch eine Legende der König wie
wir gerade gehört haben das ist ja auch
teilweise viel zu lange her viele haben
ihn gar nicht mehr spielen sehen es geht
mehr darum was er für das Land wirklich
bedeutet hat und das war das ja als
einer der ersten vielleicht dieses große
stolze Land auf die Welt Bühne gehoben
hat sichtbar gemacht hat in der ganzen
Welt durch seine fußballerischen Erfolge
er war aber Jahrzehnte das Gesicht
Brasiliens und das jemals eine Person
die selbst als armen Verhältnissen kamen
sich durch Fleiß und Talent nach oben
gearbeitet hat und damit ein Vorbild war
Generation hat doch
Gesellschaftsschichten übergreifend und
dieses Vorbild ist eben jetzt verstorben
Dankeschön der Himmel weint auch das war
Christoph röckerath live vor dem
maracana-stadion in Rio de Janeiro der
ehemalige zdf-kommentator Bela rethi
hatte das Glück Pelé persönlich gut
kennenzulernen wie und wo und Wasser an
seinem Idol so bewunderte das können Sie
in seiner Würdigung Nachlesen auf
heute.de oder in der ZDF heute App
in die USA jahrelang hatte sich Donald
Trump vehement gegen die
Veröffentlichung seiner Steuerunterlagen
gewehrt heute stellte sie ein
Kongressausschuss ins Netz auf den knapp
6000 Seiten findet man wenig rühmliches
der ehemalige US-Präsident zahlte kaum
Einkommenssteuern und er nutzte
fragwürdige Methoden um Steuern zu
vermeiden seine Anhänger sehen ihn
weiter als Opfer einer Hexenjagd aus
Washington Benjamin Daniel
da rollen Sie die Steuerunterlagen um
deren Veröffentlichung seit Jahren hart
gekämpft wurde nun sind sie also publik
aus den Dokumenten ist der sichtlich das
Trump jahrelang so gut wie keine Steuern
abgeführt hat vor allem deshalb weil
angeblich die Verluste seiner
Unternehmen so hoch gewesen sein dass er
kaum Gewinner Einfuhr Trump äußerte sich
bisher nur schriftlich
die Demokraten hätten das nie machen
sollen und der Oberste Gerichtshof hätte
es nicht zulassen sollen es wird zu
schrecklichen Dingen führen für viele
Menschen die große Spaltung Amerikas
wird nun noch viel schlimmer werden die
radikalen Linken Demokraten benutzen
alles als Waffe
außerdem bemerkenswert die meisten
Steuererklärungen wurden von der
amerikanischen Finanzbehörde iOS nicht
überprüft was eigentlich bei jedem
US-Präsidenten üblich ist der Verdacht
steht im Raum dass der damalige
Behördenleiter der als Trump nahe gilt
dabei eine Rolle spielen könnte einer
seiner Vorgänger meldete sich heute zu
Wort
ich beobachte die Vorgänge mit großer
Sorge es wundert mich dass der ios-chef
der damals im Amt war nicht klar gesagt
hat wir müssen uns die Steuererklärungen
anschauen und nach Recht und Gesetz
handeln also ich denke die Finanzbehörde
hat einiges zu erklären
ob Trumps steuerangaben im juristisch
gefährlich werden könnten ist noch nicht
klar in jedem Fall werden sie seinen
politischen Gegnern in die Hände spielen
wie der Rest der langen problemliste
Trumps zu der nun wieder ein Neues
hinzugekommen ist
Johannes Hano in New York was genau
könnte dafür Trump unangenehm werden
also eine Antwort auf diese Frage kann
es so schnell nicht geben es handelt
sich hier um mehrere tausend
seitensteuerunterlagen aus einem
hochkomplexen Geflecht aus mehrere als
400 Firmen vor dem selbst die
amerikanischen steuerbürde immer wieder
kapituliert hat aber viele Beobachter
hier rechnen damit dass man aus diesen
Unterlagen möglicherweise Antworten auf
eine Frage bekommen könnte die Trump
werden seine gesamten Präsidentschaft
verfolgt hat nämlich ob Trump im eigenen
Interesse gehandelt im Interesse
Amerikas oder möglicherweise im
Interesse eine ausländischen macht Trump
hat das während seiner Präsidentschaft
immer wieder empört zurückgewiesen aber
Fakt ist vor seiner Präsidentschaft hat
er immer wieder viel Geld von russischen
Oligarchen angenommen immer dann wenn er
Klamm war oder auch sein Sohn hat sich
immer wieder damit gebrüstet dass selbst
wenn amerikanische Banken kein Geld
gegeben haben das war mit russischen
Geld geflutet werden würde die Frage ist
jetzt hat das auch während seiner
Präsidentschaft weiter stattgefunden und
da sitzen jetzt jede Menge Leute dran
die diese Unterlagen durchforsten und da
könnte es für Trump dann möglicherweise
noch mal eng werden danke schön für
diese Einschätzung aus new Johannes
Hanau
China kämpft mit einer heftigen
corona-welle deswegen verschärfen immer
mehr Länder ihre Regeln für Reisende aus
dem asiatischen Land etwa die USA Indien
Italien und jetzt auch Spanien ordnen
Kontrollen an den Flughäfen an in
Deutschland hält
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
eine testpflicht noch nicht für nötig
Frank Buchwald
die Spanier tun ist bereits Italien
jetzt auch wer aus China kommt muss zum
corona-test nach dem Ausbruch in der
Volksrepublik wollen die Behörden
verhindern dass neue gefährliche
Virusvarianten eingeschleppt werden kein
Grund zur Panik sagt der deutsche
Gesundheitsminister jedoch die Varianten
die wir derzeit sehen geben keinen
Anlass für also die antigen-test auf
routinebasis in auf der anderen Seite
können wir andere Varianten nicht
ausschließen und um diese frühzeitig
erkennen zu können über werden wir die
Flughäfen in Europa engmaschig
überwachen allerdings im europäischen
Rahmen denn Flüge von China nach Europa
nehmen nach dem Lockdown wieder zu
alleine in Frankfurt landen jede Woche
11 Maschinen viele Passagiere sollen
infiziert sein eine unmittelbare Gefahr
für Deutschland aber sehen Experten
bisher nicht die meisten Menschen hier
sein geimpft
wir sind in Deutschland deswegen in
einer anderen Situation weil wir durch
ein ausgewogenes Maß von Schutzmaßnahmen
einerseits und einer großflächigen
Impfkampagne andererseits uns einfach
besser geschützt haben ein genaues
Monitoring seit der noch sinnvoll heißt
es aus den Ländern es kommen nun vor
allem darauf an mögliche Virusvarianten
aufzuspüren
die können wir nur feststellen wenn wir
wieder mehr testen auch mehr PCR-Tests
und die dann sequenzieren nur dann
werden wir Gewissheit haben was wirklich
unterwegs ist China ist im Moment ja
eine Art Blackbox für uns und deswegen
macht sicher Sinn sich da abzusprechen
aber ich werde noch mal dafür dass wir
eine europaweite Lösung anstreben so
sieht es auch die EU-Kommission für
kommende Woche hat sie die
Gesundheitsminister der Mitgliedstaaten
zum Krisengipfel eingeladen
in Myanmar ist die entmachtete
Regierungschefin zu G erneut verurteilt
worden diesmal zu weiteren sieben Jahren
die
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin sitzt bereits
seit einem Militärputsch vor fast zwei
Jahren im Gefängnis seitdem musste sich
die 77-Jährige in einer ganzen Serie von
Verfahren verantworten zuletzt wegen
angeblicher Korruption ihre Gesamtstrafe
kommt mit 33 Jahren einer lebenslangen
haftgleich
russlands Präsident Putin will die
militärische Zusammenarbeit mit China
künftig vertiefen das sagte er in einer
Videokonferenz mit Chinas Staatschefin
außerdem werde ich hier im Frühjahr nach
Moskau kommen laut Chinas
Staatsfernsehen betonte hi man werde
seine objektive und faire Haltung zum
Krieg in der Ukraine Beibehalten der Weg
zufriedensgesprächen werde Zitat holprig
groß und mächtig sein wie einst das
russische Reich oder die Sowjetunion
viele sagen das sei es was Präsident
Putin antreibt vor genau 100 Jahren
wurde die Sowjetunion gegründet
im bollscheuthe in Moskau wurde der
Vertrag unterzeichnet eine freiwillige
Vereinigung gleichberechtigter Völker
sollte die Sowjetunion sein das
Riesenreich der Sozialistischen
Sowjetrepubliken wurde aber mit harter
Hand von Moskau aus regiert
Kollektivierung der Landwirtschaft
Industrialisierung
international Stärke demonstrieren darum
ging es wie das heute in Russland
gesehen wird zeigt Sebastian e
die Ausstellung über die glorreichen
Errungenschaften der Sowjetrepubliken in
Moskau ein Ort der die Macht und die
Stärke der ehemaligen Sowjetunion
symbolisieren soll eine Demonstration
der Einheit
Museumsführer wladislav klimow erlebt in
den vergangenen Jahren eine gestiegene
Sowjet Nostalgie in Russland
die Sowjetunion ist sehr beliebt
besonders bei denen die in ihr geboren
wurden und wir sehen dass die Besucher
kommen um sich daran zu erinnern und um
in nostalgischen Gefühlen zu schwelgen
der Dezember ist in Russland ein Monat
des sowjet-gedenkens erst vor ein paar
Tagen wurde sogar dem Diktator und
Massenmörder Stalin gedacht am Roten
Platz legen Kommunisten an seinem Grab
Blumen nieder über 60% der Russen sehen
den Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion
mittlerweile negativ auch weil russlands
Präsident Wladimir Putin die Sowjet
ihrer glorifiziert aber nicht wegen
ihrer kommunistischen Ideologie sondern
vor allem wegen ihres großmachtströms
[Musik]
der Größte energiedicke für mich war das
genauso eine Tragödie wie für die
meisten Menschen in unserem Land was
bedeutet denn der Zerfall der
Sowjetunion das war der Zerfall des
historischen Russlands das damals als
Sowjetunion bezeichnet wurde wir haben
40% unseres Territoriums verloren
doch das Rat der Geschichte kann auch
Vladimir Putin nicht zurückdrehen auch
wenn das repressive Russland heute
zunehmend Parallelen zur Sowjetunion
aufweist und bei einigen ehemaligen
Sowjetrepubliken hat gerade der
Einmarsch in die Ukraine alte Ängste vor
russischer Dominanz wieder aufleben
lassen
zu heiß zu trocken und sehr sonnig so
bilanziert der Deutsche Wetterdienst das
ablaufende Jahr hierzulande mit einer
Jahresmitteltemperatur von 10,5 Grad war
das Jahr nicht nur deutlich zu warm es
ist damit eines der zwei wärmsten Jahre
seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen der
Silvestertag morgen soll noch mal
ausgesprochen mild werden daher könnte
2022 sogar als heißestes Jahr in die
Bilanz eingehen
dieses Gewebe um Schönheit wird immer
unerträglicher die Menschen sollten sich
mehr anstrengen weniger dumm zu sein das
würde sie am besten kleiden das sagte
Vivien Westwood mal der Süddeutschen
Zeitung typisch für Sie die britische
Designerin provozierte gern auch deshalb
wurde sie so bewundert als Königin und
Sonne der Modeindustrie mit 81 ist sie
im Kreis ihrer Familie gestorben Yasin
herlein erinnert
sie wusste selbst sehr gut wie man sich
auf dem Laufsteg bewegt konnte also die
von ihr entworfenen Kleider auch selbst
tragen und dass sie über so viele
Jahrzehnte zu den allergrößten der
Branche zählte war vielleicht ihrer ganz
eigenen Herangehensweise ans Frauen
einkleiden zu verdanken
die so stark und extrem sind wie diese
sollen sie die helfen deine
Persönlichkeit hervorzuheben es sind
Kleider die dich nicht verstecken sie
unterstützen Dich
versteckt hat sie selbst sich nie die
Provokation hatte für Vivian Westwood
immer dazu gehört ein aber vielleicht
aus der Zeit als aus der
Grundschullehrerin die Mode Queen des
Punkte wurde als kostümausstatterin der
sexpistels und Ehefrau des Managers der
Band Marke McLaren mit dem sie Anfang
der 70er einen Klamottenladen eröffnete
der abwechselnd so aufregende Namen trug
wie let it rock oder Sex
der Weg zur top-designerin war gleich
wohl nicht ohne Herausforderungen sei es
für Supermodel sweet Campbell oder die
Westwood selbst Gott sei Dank half ihr
eins Gottschalk wieder auf die
Plateauschuhe breit gefächert engagierte
sie sich für politische Themen sei es
den Klimaschutz Tierschutz oder die
Freilassung des Wikileaks Gründers
Julien Assange
half ihr ehemaliger Schüler und Ehemann
Andreas Kronthaler in ihrem Mode
Imperium aus über Jahrzehnte hinweg und
für alle Ewigkeit wird ihr Name jedoch
vor allem für eines stehen starke Mode
für starke Frauen
und eines predigte sie in den letzten
Jahren immer wieder kauft weniger Welt
sorgfältiger aus
wenn es in den kommenden Tagen an ihrer
Tür klingelt dann könnten es wieder die
Sternsinger sein bei der fire in
Frankfurt zum Start der Aktion waren
rund 800 Kinder dabei verkleidet als
Heilige Drei Könige deutschlandweit
werden etwa 300.000 Sternsinger Spenden
für ärmere Länder sammeln das Motto
lautet diesmal Kinder stärken Kinder
schützen in Indonesien und weltweit
und jetzt kommst du Norbert mit einem
kleinen Stückchen sportgeschichten ja
mit Hilfe eines sehr kleinen Sportgeräts
das Gabriel Clemens in London mit viel
Gefühl und Präzision ins Ziel befördert
er ist der erste deutsche im
Viertelfinale einer Darts WM dank des
Erfolgs gegen den Schotten allen Suter
am Ende eine reine Nervensache bevor
Gabriel Clemens befreit durchatmen kann
macht er es nach bis dahin überlegen im
Spiel noch mal richtig spannend drei
Match Darts vergleichbar mit Matchbällen
im Tennis vergibt der Saarländer hier
gleich die ersten beiden auf die Doppel
18 vorbei der erste
und auch der zweite etwa später vergibt
Clemens dann auch noch seinen dritten
auf die Doppel 20
doch als danach auch sein schottischer
Gegner Alan Sultan nicht trifft
hat Clemens zum vierten Mal die Chance
zum Sieg und diesmal trifft er das
kleine Feld der Doppel 20 und Match zu
verwandeln ist dann immer irgendwie
schwer und ich glaube das hat man auch
gesehen dass der nicht so einfach fällt
Sieg in 4:1 setzen am Neujahrstag wartet
im Viertelfinale der Weltranglisten
erste German Preis
[Applaus]
nun fliegen sie wieder um den Goldenen
Adler bei der Vierschanzentournee nach
Platz 4 zum Auftakt daheim ist ein
Oberstdorfer guter Dinge wieder ein
Wörtchen um den Gesamtsieg mitsprechen
zu können
Karl Geiger hat wie er selbst sagt
wieder Bock zu springen denn nach einem
holprigen Start in die Saison der
29-Jährige rechtzeitig zur Tournee in
Topform nicht nur das Fluggefühl ist
wieder zurück sondern auch das
Selbstvertrauen der vierte Platz zum
Auftakt eine gute Ausgangsposition ein
Podestplatz am Ende dieser Tournee für
den deutschen durchaus im Bereich des
Möglichen
Sprung gelungen also ich glaube das war
der beste hier und bin schon zufrieden
mit dem Tag zufrieden ist derzeit auch
Team Kollege Andreas Wellinger gestern
sechster nun lautet das Motto der
deutschen alles riskieren und den
überragenden Norweger Halver gerade
unter Druck setzen der gewann zwar
souverän muss aber erst einmal beim
zweiten Springen in Garmisch seine Form
bestätigen
und dass wir immer ein neujahrsvergnügen
Dankeschön Norbert mit irritierenden
Temperaturen geht das ja morgen zu Ende
die Details dazu hat gleich Christa
Augen Marietta Slomka begrüßt sie im
heute-journal um 20 Uhr wir wünschen
Ihnen einen sehr schönen Abend und bis
morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend Zeit für den Jahresrückblick
2022 ja es gab 15% weniger Regen als
noch im Mittel der letzten 30 Jahre mit
plus 1,2 Grad war es neben 2018 das
wärmste und auch das sonnigste Jahr seit
mask beginnen mit außergewöhnlichen plus
21% beim Sonnenschein also zu sonnig zu
trocken zu warm und zu warm für diese
Jahreszeit geht es jetzt auch weiter
schon heute Nacht sinken die Werte nicht
unter 4 Grad im Westen bleiben sie sogar
auf zwei stellig dazu ist es aber sehr
regnerisch und teilweise auch stürmisch
und so geht das morgen am Silvestertag
weiter vor allem im Norden sind bisschen
tiefe Lage stürmische Böden möglich auf
dem Bergen sogar Orkanböen und es regnet
auch vor allem im Nordwesten teils
kräftig von Süden her da trocknet es im
Tagesverlauf aber ab und an den Alpen
und im Südwesten schaut auch häufig die
Sonne aus und diese Sonne vor allem aber
diese stramme Südwestströmung sorgen
morgen für Rekordtemperaturen mit
zwischen 18 und 21 Grad war es an
Silvester in Deutschland noch nie so
warm selbst im Norden bleibt es bei 11
Grad also so richtig frieren muss in der
Silvesternacht keiner im Norden haben
wir den Regen und den Wind im Süden ist
es trocken und windstill und auch das
neue Jahr geht zu mild und unbeständig
weiter tschüss